well salt water in southern Nevada not
too often do those words really get
uttered in the same breath but for our
neighbors just to the West in California
that's a whole different story in
tonight's report on the California Water
Hogs eight news now investigator Kyle
Payne looks at while that salt water
along the California coastline is not
turned into drinking water Kyle Brian
and Denise that Coast is 840 miles long
but not too much of this being used to
solve the war over Colorado River water
in San Diego 10 in Los Angeles the
number is zero zero it's expensive and
most California residents are not
enthusiastic about disrupting their
beaches and shorelines
during us it was you know drought was
the way of life having grown up in Las
Vegas and spending her entire adult life
in Southern California and moved out to
San Diego for college and been your subs
environmental engineer Michelle Peters
knows the deal it's very complicated I
definitely understand the
from the red Central perspective you're
growing up there and as the technical
compliance manager for the giant water
treatment plant developer Poseidon at
this desalination plant in Carlsbad
right across the street from This
Magnificent Beach where the Deep Blue
Pacific seems to go on forever Peters
knows people in Las Vegas are tired of
waiting for California to start using
some of that beautiful ocean water to
help alleviate the crisis on the
Colorado River I understand a decent
amount on on each side the Carlsbad
plant is an impressive network of pipes
and Potions tubing and tanks we're
producing some high
water supply here but getting a
desalination plant funded permitted and
passed the scrutiny of the neighbors is
not always a breeze just ask the people
here in Huntington Beach who have been
battling for decades about putting one
on this industrial site that's never
going to happen here Huntington Beach is
one of just a handful of proposed
desalination sites in California one day
they're building and one day they're not
in fact there's only a dozen existing
diesel facilities in the entire state
which amounts to less than one
desalination plan for every 3 million
people in California getting the
Carlsbad plan to where it is today was
well no day at the beach considering it
took almost 20 years to get it permitted
it's a process they're very familiar
with in the lovely Oceanside City of
Dana Point where another engineer the
Project's general manager rich shintaku
is hoping the South Coast Water
District's proposed desalination plant
holds water well the Project's going
pretty well pretty well maybe but you
can hear the hesitation in shintaku's
voice that's because among other things
the area around Dana Point is vulnerable
to earthquakes and if the ground would
have Shake too much it would rupture
their Pipeline and the whole project
would be sunk this project cost 140
million dollars just to get started
and they expect it to cost 6 million
dollars a year just to run the plant if
it comes to fruition as expected in 2028
and that's why we need to provide a
local drinking water solution shintaku
has been in the water business for 30
years early in his career his job was to
keep track of the Colorado River it's a
very very large problem and that's
that's an understatement right right
which is why Southern abandons want more
results but these desalination plants
are expensive and a hard sell for most
Californians and generally California
likes to protect their Coastline like
stick protect their beaches bill
hazenkamp is the manager of Colorado
resources for the Metropolitan water
district which supplies water to some 19
million Southern Californians he says
between the high price of building these
plants getting Coastal commission
approval and having to build unsightly
plants on gorgeous waterfront real
estate so details a piece of the puzzle
but it's not going to solve all the
problems
all right so Kai you mentioned one of
those took 20 years to actually bring to
fruition is it the expense or is it just
the Aesthetics of the planet it's it's
both both but to be fair the officials
we spoke with about desalination made
sure to tell us that water reuse and
recycling was a far less far less
expensive and controversial to less time
consuming opinion option than
desalination still in Los Angeles for
instance it's only two percent of the
amount of their water supply being
recycled thanks for that Kyle maybe uh
stay away from the beaches in California
for a bit good idea all right